who doesn't love Judge Judy her  no-nonsense attitude has captivated  audiences for 22 years yes and now she's  sharing the secret of her success only  to et all rise we just do what has been  successful and what has been successful  is listening to information cutting  through the baloney telling a story once  upon a time the end next that's the  formula if it's not broken we're not  gonna fix it you left out a word stupid  Judge Judy pays that success forward she  funds the foundation her honor which her  daughter Nicole developed it fares young  women with professional mentors very  honest advice over the years she had  definitely convinced me that beauty  fades and some is forever very good to  know it's something my mom I think also  said about me so Wow well look at you  now a mom look at you now Bob as for how  long Judge Judy will be testing that  theory in a TV curt room well she's  signed on to do the show through 2021  yeah  [Music]  [Applause]